et notre invité politique ce matin cette
année Genevard bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés les
républicains du Doubs vice-président
délégué du parti on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
avec vous de la réforme de retraite
puisque Elizabeth borne n'a présente
donc en fin d'après-midi ce sera 17h30
la piste retenue devrait être celle d'un
report de l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
avec allongement et accélération de la
durée de cotisation
Erik sciotti semble dire banco est-ce
qu'on peut dire qu'un compromis a été
trouvé entre le gouvernement et les
républicains alors ça nous pourrons le
dire à l'issue des débats le texte n'est
pas encore présenté donc attendons de le
voir ensuite il y aura les débats au
Parlement au terme duquel nous pourrons
dire oui là nous avons pu imprimer notre
marque faire valoir nos points de vue
faire adopter nos propositions et là
nous le voterons ça veut dire qu'il y a
encore des efforts à faire le vote des
républicains n'est pas acquis pour le
gouvernement ne peut pas dire d'emblée
le vote est acquis avant même que le
débat n'ait eu lieu vous comprenez bien
qu'il y a là quelque chose qui est
contraire à l'esprit de nos institutions
il faut que le débat se déroule ce que
je peux vous dire à ce stade c'est que
le gouvernement a infléchi sa position
en fonction de nos demandes nous nous
voulions une réforme nous sommes
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut une
réforme
1984 actifs pour un retraité aujourd'hui
1,7 actif pour un retraité ça ne peut
pas tenir chacun peut le comprendre mais
ce n'est pas n'importe quelle réforme et
mener n'importe comment il faut une
progressivité il faut qu'elle soit juste
pour qu'elle soit acceptable au stade où
on en est vous êtes sûr que Elizabeth
borne parce qu'elle va présenter ce soir
reprendra l'essentiel aux propositions
sur on n'est jamais sûr tant que les
choses ne sont pas posées en tout cas on
a eu un certain nombre de discussions
avec la première ministre nous lui avons
dit que 65 ans c'était trop brutal que
ce sera 64 ce sera 64 nous nous disons
63 à la fin du quinquennat 2027 une
clause de revoyure au moment de
l'élection présidentielle puisque c'est
le moment où se repose les grandes
orientations de la politique le
gouvernement accepte parce que s'il
était du côté de la majorité
présidentielle cette histoire de clause
de revoyure n'était pas c'était pas
prévu en 2027 une nouvelle élection
présidentielle rebattra les cartes et si
en 2027 il s'avère nécessaire d'aller
au-delà ce sera jusqu'à 74 ça quand même
parce que vous avez fait quand même une
campagne présidentielle même deux
campagnes présidentielles en prenant un
report de l'âge légal de départ à 65 ans
et maintenant vous parlez de 63 ans en
2027 avec une clause de revoyure vous
avez beaucoup prochain Emmanuel Macron
de manquer de courage sur cette réforme
de retraite est-ce que là ce ne sont pas
les républicains qui sont pas du tout
courage d'abord il vous a pas échappé
qu'on a perdu la présidentielle donc si
on fait les mêmes propositions on est on
a compris que les Français ne voulaient
pas plus la période est compliquée pour
les Français la question de l'inflation
la perte de pouvoir d'achat le hausse du
coup l'énergie l'instabilité sociale
tout ça fait que
on constate d'abord que Emmanuel Macron
Macron a raté le coche il y a cinq ans
presque 6 maintenant c'est une réforme
qui aurait dû faire en début de
quinquennat dernier mais les
républicains disent 63 puis 64 si besoin
donc il y a rien de véritablement
contradictoires avec
ce que nous avons dit depuis le début
nous ne voulons pas
à la présidentielle oui mais on a perdu
la présidentielle à cause de ça fait
partie du du pack donc à partir de là il
faut aussi tenir compte du contexte
politique de ce que nous disent les
Français et du moment où c'est très
forme arrive c'est un moment difficile
pour les Français donc ça impose une
progressivité quand nous disons de 63
ans en 2027 c'est peu oupru la position
c'est la position du Sénat des
républicains et du sang décentrices au
Sénat et le gouvernement
si j'ai bien compris annonce aussi cette
progressivité est-ce que c'est la
position de tout le monde chez vous
c'est 64 ans avec un logement de la
durée de cotisation parce qu'on entend
notamment une petite musique du côté
d'Aurélien Pradier qui dit lui que les
annuités doivent primer sur le report de
l'âge légal
le souci de certains d'entre nous et de
dire il faut considérer les carrières
longues ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt on ne peut pas leur
infliger 63 ans l'idéal serait que dès
lors que vous avez vos annuités
c'est-à-dire 43 années de cotisation
quel que soit l'âge il faudrait pouvoir
partir en retraite sans des cotes c'est
ça l'objectif y arriverons nous je ne
sais pas le débat le dira mais c'est ce
que vous demanderez au Parlement
à mon avis c'est quelque chose qui sera
demandé par notre groupe
de pouvoir aller de pouvoir considérer
le nombre d'annuités ça permet de
prendre en compte ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt voir très tôt c'est ça
la demande que font certains de nos
collègues et vous êtes sûr qu'il y aura
une unité chez les républicains ou
Aurélien Pradier pourrait avoir une
position différente
est-ce qu'il peut avoir une pension
différente devant on est d'accord sur
les fondamentaux oui il faut une réforme
oui ça passe par l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation qui aura fatalement
une incidence sur l'âge oui il faut
prendre en compte les carrières longues
les carrières pénibles les droits
familiaux l'emploi des seniors à
amélioré ça fait partie des fondamentaux
sur lesquels on est d'accord pour le
reste il y a
quelques
nuances qu'il me semble possible de de
pouvoir
je dirais rendre compatible au delà des
nuances c'est ce qui a pas un risque et
certains députés les républicains à
l'assemblée qui soit tentés de prendre
des positions divergentes pour marquer
leur opposition gouvernement et leur
singularité au sein du groupe ce qu'on
verra pas forcément au Sénat par exemple
écoutez c'est la richesse du débat du
débat parlementaire nous verrons bien
maintenant ce que je dis à mes collègues
c'est que on a un impératif d'unité
autour d'eriksiotti notre nouveau
président il faut pouvoir faire bloc
Sénat assemblée partie et parler d'une
voix la plus convergente possible c'est
une condition de la crédibilité donc que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités le
débat il aura lieu
le moment de vérité ce sera le le vote
de la loi on nous verrons bien vous
dites
impératif d'unité et il existe pas
encore aujourd'hui elle existe pas
encore si tu veux si je crois que nous
sommes conscients à droite que nous
jouons notre crédibilité nous avons
toujours réclamé une réforme des
retraites nous ne pouvons pas nous
délger et je crois que c'est la ligne de
l'immense majorité des parlementaires
les républicains il y a une autre ligne
rouge qui a été dictée par Éric sotti
c'est la question des pensions minimales
à 1200 roues qu'il veut voir s'appliquer
à tous les retraités non pas seulement
au futur retraités comme ça semble être
le cas dans le projet du gouvernement
est-ce que ça aussi c'est pas en
contradiction avec ce que vous dites
c'est à dire il faut faire attention à
la dépense publique
alors la question de la dépense publique
vous le savez elle est déterminante on
voit aujourd'hui que la France dépense
trop mal on le voit notamment dans le
domaine de la santé
une dépense publique qui n'est pas
toujours efficace donc c'est pas tant
c'est à la fois le volume de la dépense
publique mais la façon dont elle est
elle est conduite si vous voulez
pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes attachés
à un minimum vieillesse à 1200 euros
pour une carrière complète d'abord parce
que dans notre pays il y a près de 2
millions de Français retraités qui
touchent moins de 1000 euros donc c'est
très faible et c'est à prendre en
considération et c'est à la faveur de
cette réforme des retraites qu'il faut
pouvoir repenser le minimum vieillesse
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que c'est
très important que nos auditeurs le
l'entendent c'est que cette réforme des
retraites elle n'a pas pour seule
finalité une amélioration budgétaire du
régime des retraites bien sûr il s'agit
de sauver le régime par répartition mais
il faut absolument l'accompagner de
mesures sociales et notamment la
revalorisation du minimum vieillesse à
1200 euros pour les nouveaux retraités
mais aussi pour ceux qui sont déjà à la
retraite également à ce que les
retraites les pensions soient réindexées
sur l'inflation alors ça ça fait partie
des demandes que nous dirigeons depuis
un moment
ça paraît juste alors
il faudra étudier l'atterrissage
budgétaire de la mesure mais en tout cas
cette question de l'amélioration du
montant des pensions est une question
centrale dans les mesures sociales que
vous évoquez sur le l'employé militaire
des seniors par exemple qui est très
basse en France parce que vous attendez
des choses en particulier vous avez
demandé des choses spécifiques mais déjà
il faut changer presque de philosophie
d'état d'esprit pendant des décennies on
a incité les seigneurs à partir les
entreprises elles-mêmes avaient intérêt
à ce que les seniors partent plutôt
d'abord parce que c'est une main
d'oeuvre plus coûteuse qu'une manœuvre
récemment manœuvre plus jeune et puis
aussi parce que
il n'avait pas trop de scrupules à le
faire dans la mesure où les seigneurs
étaient largement pris en charge par
l'assurance chômage et donc tout inciter
à un départ précoce du seniors or
l'équilibre du régime de retraite passe
par un meilleur emploi du seniors il
faut que les gens travaillent plus
longtemps quand ils le peuvent quand
évidemment
ce sont des carrières très longues
pénibles etc mais il faut que les
seigneurs puissent travailler plus
longtemps en plus je dirais c'est une
richesse formidable pour une entreprise
parce que sur les savoir-faire c'est de
la transmission c'est de l'apprentissage
le simple report de l'âge légal ne
suffira pas mécaniquement à améliorer
l'employabilité des seigneurs dans le
pays alors c'est pas tout à fait la vie
par exemple de François Asselin de la
CME qui dit mécaniquement
l'allongement et vous vous croyez à ça
moi je pense qu'il y aura un effet
mécanique
dans une proportion que je ne sais pas
évaluer mais ça ne suffira pas il faut
qu'il y ait des dispositions qui
incitent les entreprises à conserver les
seniors à embaucher des jeunes et à
conserver les seniors ça peut passer par
des allègements de charges il y a on
connaît les dispositifs qui font passer
par un index avec des sanctions pour les
entreprises qui ne respectent pas dans
le patronat ne veut pas exactement alors
l'index ça permet de faire le point sur
la situation maintenant est-ce que ça
aura des conséquences coercitives
pénalisante pour les entreprises c'est
peut-être pas le moment quand même de
charger la barque qu'il y a un index
soit qu'on puisse avoir exactement que
l'entreprise comme elle le fait pour la
parité d'ailleurs il y a des index de
parité il peut y avoir des index
d'employés d'employés habilités des
seniors mais en tout cas non je pense
qu'il faut laisser aux entreprises le
temps de s'adapter à ces nouvelles à
cette nouvelle donne de la nécessité de
l'emploi des seniors après on verra mais
je pense qu'elles ont beaucoup d'autres
difficultés à gérer pour l'instant sur
le véhicule législatif entre guillemets
puisque le gouvernement devrait passer
par un budget rectificatif ce qui permet
d'utiliser le 49 3 sans
Aubine serré j'allais dire s'engager une
cartouche pour un prochain texte est-ce
que ça c'est un problème pour vous de
passer par un budget rectificatif
non c'est pas un problème
c'est pas un problème par nature je
pense que le gouvernement veut se donner
la possibilité de recourir au 49-3 en
tant que de besoin avec un risque
politique tout de même quand on fait
passer un texte avec le 49-3 ça
évidemment un impact politique
le 49-3 disons que il faut que le débat
puisse se dérouler se dérouler à la
loyal que les oppositions puissent faire
valoir leur point de vue avec un temps
plus contraint que ça va être un texte
normal alors effectivement le temps sera
plus contraint mais on est au pied du
mur de la vérité la Chine ou une
réformons pas si nous ne faisons pas
cette réforme on court à la catastrophe
on va creuser des déficits qui
conduiront un manquablement à ce que
nous ne voulons pas se dire diminuer les
pensions ou augmenter les cotisations
donc le coût du travail mieux se débat
parce que la gauche notamment la France
insoumise dit que il déposeront des
dizaines des centaines voire des
milliers d'amendements pour vous ça va
être un problème pour le débat
parlementaire
si les certaines oppositions veulent à
tout prix faire obstruction des bas cela
conduira aux 49-3 on peut pas déplorer
l'usage du 49-3 et faire en sorte d'y
conduire le gouvernement donc j'espère
que l'esprit de responsabilité prévaudra
mais bon le dépôt d'amendement fait
partie de la liberté du parlementaire
vous le savez donc nous il y a la
bataille parlementaire autour des
retraites mais il va surtout y avoir la
bataille de l'opinion est-ce que vous
estimez comme François Bayrou par
exemple le patron du MoDem que on n'a
pas assez utilisé le temps qui vient de
s'écouler là pour négocier et concerter
on n'a pas assez utilisé ce temps pour
expliquer le fond de la réforme aux
Français
vous savez sous la précédentement nature
Jean-Paul Delevoy a passé trois ans à
concerter avec le résultat qu'on connaît
ça a été un flop total
pour une réforme à laquelle personne ne
comprenait rien la réforme à points nous
nous disions depuis le début il faut
simplement toucher les paramètres c'est
ce qui sera le plus simple et le plus
efficace
c'est aussi difficile à expliquer ce
n'est pas une question de temps de la
négociation parce que je crois que
la concertation elle peut toujours être
améliorée mais il y a un moment où
chacun prend ses responsabilités ce qui
est plus préoccupant c'est effectivement
l'opposition des Français à cette
réforme ils sont majoritaires à dire
nous ne voulons pas toutes les études
d'opinion le disent voilà encore que
quand on affine les choses dans par
exemple dans dans notre électorat
nous voyons qu'il y a un avis favorable
à la réforme donc nous nous sommes en
accord avec
notre base
de nombreux Français savent qu'on ne
peut pas faire autrement que de réformer
si on veut sauver ce qui est un pilier
du contrat social en France c'est-à-dire
le régime par répartition basé sur la
solidarité entre générations maintenant
ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de faire
comprendre aux Français à quel point
cette cette réforme elle n'est pas
indifférente aux difficultés qui sont
les leurs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle si on demande
aux Français travailler un peu plus
longtemps on a sorti cette demande cet
effort qui leur est demandé d'un certain
nombre de mesures qui vont grandement
améliorer la situation des retraités ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut que les
parlementaires républicains les piliers
du parti aillent sur les plateaux pour
défendre le la réforme qui sera
présentée par le gouvernement et si oui
est-ce que ça risque pas de se faire au
détriment de votre image c'est à dire
qu'à un moment il y a un certain nombre
de gens qui se disent que finalement
vous êtes des supplétifs
du pouvoir vous êtes plus dans
l'opposition alors on défend pas la
réforme du gouvernement on n'est pas là
pour défendre le gouvernement on est là
pour défendre auprès des Français les
convictions qui nous semblent
importantes pour eux
voilà le travail que on s'apprête à
faire au Parlement c'est un travail pour
les Français donc il s'agit pas d'être
les supplétifs de qui que ce soit bien
sûr c'est une difficulté politique
certains ont fait le choix de la
démagogie le rassemblement national dit
retraite à 60 ans alors que
très franchement ils le savent que ça
n'est pas tenable mais par démagogie il
revendique quelque chose qui ne peut pas
qui qui reviendrait à revenir en arrière
puisqu'on est toujours dû à 62 ans ils
veulent la retraite à 60 ans comme
François Mitterrand qui en 81 nous a mis
dans cette difficulté
dont on voit aujourd'hui les
conséquences donc on n'a pas fait le
choix de la démagogie mais on fait pas
le choix du Ralliement non plus si cette
réforme si nous sommes amenés à voter
cette réforme c'est parce qu'elle
portera notre marque
question sur un vote qui va avoir lieu
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée Stéphane oui
dont on parle moins puisque l'actualité
est complètement concentrée sur la
réforme des retraites mais il y a la loi
sur les énergies renouvelables qui est
programmée aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
qu'est-ce qui va sortir du chapeau c'est
très incertain je pense que ça négocie
en coulisse sérieusement nous nous on
républicains nous avons dit que nous ne
voterions pas cette loi à l'Assemblée
nationale d'abord parce que les choses
sont prises
oui mais les choses ont ils ne vous a
pas échappé que le texte modifié par le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
n'est plus le texte du Sénat notamment
sur le veto des mers
ce texte finalement
prend les choses à l'envers puisque le
Gouvernement s'attache à promouvoir les
énergies renouvelables viendra ensuite
un texte sur le nucléaire et puis au
final une loi sur la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie n'avez-vous
pas le sentiment qu'il fallait prendre
les choses à l'envers c'est-à-dire
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
puis nucléaire plus énergies
renouvelable
en matière énergétique le gouvernement
vraiment a conduit une politique qui est
non seulement illisible incompréhensible
mais aussi inopérante contenue des
besoins et des difficultés que
connaissent les Français en la matière
un mot sur votre partie pour terminer
puisque on attend la future équipe de
direction est-ce que vous savez quelle
place vous occuperez dans cette future
écoutez je ne commenterai pas c'est la
responsabilité du Président je serai je
à la place que et à en fonction que l'on
me confiera vous la connaissez déjà et
je travaillerai comme je l'ai toujours
fait au sein de l'équipe dirigeante ou
non mais en tout cas forcément dans la
future direction
ce stade juste une question ça fait plus
d'un mois qu'Eric Ciotti était désigné
président des républicains pourquoi
est-ce que son équipe est toujours pas
constituée c'est normal que ce soit si
long alors sur ce moi il vous a pas
échappé qui a eu 15 jours pour la trêve
des confiseurs
généralement c'est un temps où chacun a
besoin de se ressourcer en famille donc
et puis
je pense que c'est imminent maintenant
donc votre impatience va bientôt être
[Musique]
enrichissement du débat aussi
une voie unique un parti caporalisé
c'est forcément un parti qui est
condamnée à s'étiolée donc
croyez-moi il faut s'appuyer sur toutes
les richesses tous les talents mais avec
toujours l'impératif inité 2 de
cohérence durant la campagne pour la
présidence du parti avec soutien avait
dit qu'il souhaitait que Laurent
Wauquiez se déclare très rapidement des
2023 est-ce qu'il doit ce que c'est
toujours d'actualité ce qui ne doit le
faire rapidement pour vous il lui
appartiendra de le dire en tout cas il a
exprimé très clairement le choix de
porter Laurent Wauquiez à la candidature
à la présidente et à la présidence de la
République
je pense qu'il n'a absolument pas varié
dans son soutien
et après il appartiendra il appartiendra
ou à Laurent Wauquiez de dire le moment
qui lui paraît le plus opportun merci
Anne va merci beaucoup
arrêté notre invité ce matin la ligne de
vestrance évidemment la réforme des
retraites pour les retraites c'est à la
Une de Ouest-France merci beaucoup on
passe au chef d'État on va parler
réforme des retraites